the next question is from John it says
in one of the earlier chapters of dances
with dragons
Tyrion mentioned 16 Wonders 7 natural
and 9 man-made this is going to be a
more specific question I guess he's not
sure if they all get spelled out in the
rest of the book he's only on page
through 27 they don't they don't ok
and he's guessing that the wall and the
Titan of Braavos are two man-made ones
he's right all right ok yes I had a
little more about those you know tearing
there's no one in the books as a
voracious reader so in one of his
chapters in an early draft I had him
remembering as he was on this continent
Essos for the first time he's never left
Westeros before reflecting on these
these books that have written the
centuries before by a traveler from
Westeros who had written wonders and
wonders made of man and there was some
paragraphs about though what they were
and it was an interesting background
story but it did kind of slowed the
story so I kept in the just a oblique
reference but took out the more detailed
explanation of it um guess you don't
always know what kind of questions are
gonna come up but the mark of Bora Bora
is that how you say that
Michael Burrell okay what yes that he
says this is Coleco says I think I
missed something because I can't figure
out what it is is that a question you
can answer the mark of Burrell yeah well
he might be referring to there's one
particular family a very minor family
who appears only one chapter but they're
Islanders and I mentioned that the
there's they they have webbed fingers
and toes they're a trait that runs in
their lineage going back generations
some of them habits of them don't so
that may be what he's referring to I
guess our fans dig deep they do yes drew
wants to know exactly what were your
interest as a child that possibly
influenced your writing as an adult
well I was I you know I suppose today
you'd say I was a geek or a nerd in
terms of my interests as a kid I've read
comic books I read science fiction and
fantasy I lived a lot in my own in my
own mind I played a lot of games you
know we didn't have a video games back
then but I played board games like risk
and monopoly and so forth but I think
one of the big things that influenced me
and my taste was was our financial
situation I mean my we never had much
money in my family we lived in the
projects we didn't even own a car we
never went anywhere my world was sort of
bounded I lived on First Street in
Bayonne my school was on Fifth Street
it's like 99% of my life was spent
between first Street and fifth Street
and those little five block area but
Balin is a peninsula and we have New
York Bay on one side Newark Bay on the
other side and the two bodies of water
connected by a deep water channel called
to kill Vaughn Cole and the projects
that I lived in happened to be right on
1st Street so directly across from us
was the kill Vaughn Cole and beyond that
Staten Island and it's a deep-water
channel where many ships bound for
important who were to come and go so I
was a kid who never went anywhere and
not even like to the lake or to New York
City which was not too far away and yet
I would watch these big ships pass every
day and all through the night with flags
from all around the world from from
China and Liberia and South America and
I'd start to imagine all these places
and they did I think it woke a hunger
and me for seeing distant wonders and
then creating distant wonders making up
stories about places I would go to
things I would see or you know
transposed to my characters so
I took the travels in my imagination
that I was not able to take in in my
actual life and have continued to do so
how do you pronounce Aaron gray Jays
title damn fair that's from Rob I'd damp
air dam hair yes I should have put a
hyphen in between this is because he's
all wet okay that makes a lot of sense
Cynthia asks our wildlings related to
the humans well these are humans
yeah they're just humans who happen to
live beyond the wall and you know their
culture has evolved differently because
they're not subject to Kings or laws or
Lords and they're they're more of a
tribal society village society living in
very harsh conditions this is a question
that asks if you have a favorite
character in the series Tyrion and why
because he's fun all right